So much better than your performing
under pressure,
whether it's me or anybody else is the
same.
You know,
I have the same pressures as anyone
else.
There's time,
there's performance,
there's financial.
I mean,
you know,
there's deadlines.
My pressures are not unique.
Everybody has the same kinds of
pressures.
Um,
but what I found,
what I find fascinating is the
interpretation of the stimuli.
Let me explain.
So I was watching the Olympics this last
summer leopards,
and I was amazed at how bad the
questions were that the reporters would
ask all the athletes,
and almost always they asked the same
question whether they were about to
compete or after they competed.
Where are you nervous?
Right?
And to a t,
all the athletes went no.
Right?
And what I realized is it's not that
they're not nervous,
it's their interpretation of what's
happening in their bodies.
I mean,
what is,
what happens when you're nervous,
right?
Your heart rate starts to go,
you're,
you know,
you sort of get a little tense.
You get a little sweaty,
right?
You have the expectation of what's
coming.
And we interpreted that as I'm nervous
now.
What's the interpretation of excited?
Your heart rate starts to go.
You become,
you're anticipating what's coming,
right?
You get a little sort of like tense.
It's all the same thing.
It's the same stimuli except these
athletes,
these,
these Olympic quality athletes have
learned to interpret the stimuli that
the rest of us would say as nervous,
as excited.
They all said the same thing.
No,
I'm not nervous.
I'm excited.
And so I've actually practiced it just
to tell myself when I start to get
nervous that this is excitement,
you know?
And so we're,
when you,
I used to speak in front of a large
audience and somebody would say,
how do you feel?
He's saying little nervous.
Now when somebody says,
how do you feel?
I'm like,
really excited actually.
And it,
it came from just sort of telling
myself,
no,
this is excitement and it becomes a
little bit automatic later on.
Um,
but it's kind of a remarkable thing to
deal with pressure by interpreting what
your body is experiencing as excitement
rather than nerves.
And it's really kind of effective.
It makes you want them to rush forward
rather than pull back and yet it's the
same experience.